joining us live fox nation host tommy
laratami these numbers are now in the
millions is the biden administration
even trying to hide this anymore
well i think if they're concerned about
an election victory in the midterms i
think the democrat party as a whole
should be concerned about the news
coming from our southern border though
they do play a lot of distraction
tactics and techniques to try to make
the american people not look to our
southern border and what's happening but
listen what we're seeing right now is
catch and release and when title 42
expires you're going to see catch and
release on steroids it's only going to
be a matter of time before these
migrants coming over phone home and say
listen we're able to get through there
are zero consequences they even give us
a bus or a plane ticket to wherever we
want to go in the united states to
escape into the shadows my goodness what
an amazing gift we are giving the rest
of the world at the expense of legal
immigrants and the american taxpayer
it's quite obvious that the bite
administration wants an open border and
if that is indeed what they want because
that is what they are showing us well
let's just come out with it and we can
campaign on that in november and you
know what's interesting about this tommy
is that two senators mark kelly and
kirsten cinema are coming out and
begging the biden administration to keep
title 42 in place they're both democrats
and they know that this will lead to
chaos in their state it doesn't look
like the biden administration is going
to listen to them though
no and i think that those democrats that
are sounding the alarm are very wise
they're in states they're not only
border states but also they're in states
that are purple states so they're very
worried about it going republican again
as they should this is going to be a
major issue but we talk a lot about
border cities and border states this is
going to be a national issue for every
american when you have millions of
people coming over it's not enough when
they're just in border cities and states
this is going to be a problem from c to
c i promise you that and every american
is going to feel it we can't absorb
millions of people we want to help the
world but we cannot have an open border
i think the world is learning that
lesson right now in ukraine finally
tommy i can't think of a topic that
screams tommy larry more than this dual
topic the secret service allegedly
paying 30 000 taxpayer dollars per month
to protect hunter biden in a malibu
mansion that's for the secret service in
the mansion next door to hunter and
black lives matter accused of using six
million dollars in donations to buy
their own mansion
boy tommy the left shore loves to spend
other people's money don't they
you know i have an idea why can't hunter
biden just move into that lavish estate
and then we can get a two-for-one deal
right but listen when we're talking
about hunter biden i think we all know
what's going on there and i think that
time will tell as those investigations
finally happen but speaking of blm you
know it's time for those leaders that
have touted blm that have donated to blm
that have encouraged and placated to blm
it's time for them to call out this
organization this organization is not
about equality it's not about justice
it's not even about black lives it's
about enriching its leaders it's a shell
organization it's a violent shell
organization and it needs to be
condemned by those that cheer led it for
so long if you want to cheer for
equality and you want to cheer for
justice and you want to draw attention
to issues that are important you can do
that but you don't need to do it from
million dollar mansions in southern
california it's sad that we even have to
say it but here we are yeah you're
absolutely right and unfortunately while
the black lives matter organization
um is now a disgrace their ideas are
still thriving when at the start of the
show we were talking to the former
police chief of rochester new york
because there have been 101 police
officers shot in the line of duty so far
this year that's a 43 increase hopefully
we can get away from these ridiculous
ideas i know it's something that is near
and dear to your heart tommy thank you
so much for joining us this morning
talking about these two issues yes we
appreciate it thank you guys